hey 42 here as I'm sure you're aware
I've just hit the big 1 million
subscribers I can't believe I'm actually
here it's been an amazing journey that
I'll never forget a few weeks ago I
asked you on Facebook to ask me
questions about myself so here's another
Q&A to celebrate this gargantuan
milestone I hope you enjoy bar cast what
was your favorite video out of all the
ones you've made I've enjoyed making
every video it's amazing how interesting
even the most mundane of topics can be
once you learn a bit about it but my
favorite was can you live forever
I found researching it absolutely
fascinating when it comes to technology
we live in a very prosperous time
there's so many mind-blowing studies
going on seeing how far we can push the
human body and reading about them really
interested me jack Harshit new port
Jordan cedar and Alex asked how long
does it take you to make a video about 3
to 6 days depending on the complexity of
the topic 70% of that is research the
over 30 percent is made up of sourcing
media filming and editing Sarah and
Christopher asked why do you wear that
certain suit in all your videos it might
seem like it but I don't always wear a
suit when I'm off video I do however
like to dress smart whenever I can if
someone goes to the effort of putting a
suit on you know they're fully committed
to the task in hand and it shows they
mean business just like if I worked in
an office when I show up for work every
day and make videos I want to look my
absolute best for you you've gone to the
effort of taking 10 to 20 minutes out of
your day to watch me and that means a
lot to me so my way of saying thank you
is looking as good as I possibly can for
you it's not about trying to look
intelligent or affirmative it's about
giving you the best experience I
possibly can when you watch my videos
Efrain Ross the mix and Eric asked what
do you do in your spare time I have two
major hobbies the first is photography
I've been doing amateur photography for
almost ten years now
and I even did it professor
for a short time but the whole business
side of it tainted the enjoyment for me
so now I do it strictly as a hobby my
second hobby is cooking I love
experimenting with food and combining
simple fresh ingredients for me cooking
is almost a game I like taking gun
ingredients and seeing what crazy things
I can do to it to really enhance the
experience of eating it we eat every day
of our lives so we shouldn't make eating
a chore it should be something we look
forward to and get excited about Alfred
asked do you prefer to have facts around
the u.s. or outside the US when it comes
to facts I really don't care what
country they're from I choose facts
based on how interesting they are and
nothing more it's as simple as that if
the majority of my facts are based
around the u.s. that's only because it's
an interesting country sure at times I
tend to focus my figures and statistics
around America but that's only because
the majority of my viewers are American
that's also why I use dollars as a
representative currency even though I'm
British because dollars are what the
majority of my viewers are used to I try
my best to make my videos friendly and
accessible to people from every country
the last thing I want to do is ostracize
anyone sheik asked why did you decide to
become a youtuber and where would you be
if you weren't a youtuber well they
already answered why I became a youtuber
in my first Q&A I'll link to that in the
description but to answer your other
question what would I be doing if I
weren't a youtuber well it's highly
likely I would be a web developer when I
was 13 I taught myself basic HTML markup
and CSS a few years later and I trained
as a graphic designer
in college but I soon realized I was
more interested with the code working
behind the scenes of a website than
making the front end look all pretty so
whilst I was in college I taught myself
of a programming
such as Python Java and C mostly out of
curiosity to see what I could do with
them I've always found a certain beauty
in code a few months after I started
YouTube I was offered a web development
job in Manchester a city in the north of
England and they had to make the tough
decision between a safe job and a cushy
office or continuing to make fascinating
videos which was what I really wanted to
do this was where my channel was still
starting up and it was still very
uncertain whether anything would
actually become of it so I took a risk
and chose YouTube luckily I made the
right decision and boy am I glad I did
because this whole experience has been
amazing I wouldn't trade it for anything
Bomi asked do you play video games if
you do what's your favourite game yes of
course
as a teenager I used to play a lot of
video games unfortunately I don't play
anymore simply because it's hard to find
the time very very occasionally I get to
kick back and play but if I do have
spare time I prefer to invested into
YouTube because I get a much bigger kick
out of making videos than shooting
aliens my all-time favorite game is
fallout free I just love the unnerving
dystopian feel to it Maurice asked would
he rather fight one poor sized dog or a
hundred duck-sized horses tough question
I put some thought into it and I think
I'd have to go with one horse sized dog
because at least I could always keep it
within my field of vision try doing that
with a hundred tiny horses those sneaky
little buggers could be up to anything
behind your back
Keisha Ginny's re Joris and Lorenzo
asked what music do you listen to when
it comes to music I'm very much stuck in
the past
I adore 60s and 70s music specifically
the British rock bands that was so
typical of the Eva The Beatles The Kinks
Led Zeppelin etc I'm also a big fan of
folk rock names such as Bob Dylan Neil
Young Simon & Garfunkel and Rodriguez
Katy asked what are your favorite books
and who are your favorite writer
it should come as no surprise that one
of my favorite book series is The
Hitchhiker's Guide books by Douglas
Adams but I read very little fiction
I love factual books I will happily read
a book on any topic when I particularly
liked reading physics books about stuff
such as black holes the universe
relativity and all that interesting
Spacey stuff that being said one of my
favorite Wood Smith's is actually a
fiction author f scott Fitzgerald the
best known for his novel The Great
Gatsby
the beautiful poetic prose meticulously
crafted into each and every paragraph
stayed with me for years after I read it
Matthew asked what's your favorite drink
my favorite drink is coffee there's
quite simply nothing better than the
smell of freshly ground coffee beans in
the morning but being British I also
love tea I know so predictable in case
you were wondering
my favorite alcoholic beverage is wine
Liam asked if you could have a
superpower what would it be and what
would you do with it I would love the
power to be able to rapidly flick from a
book and absorb all the knowledge inside
in a matter of seconds I love learning
and that would just be incredible okay I
want to be able to beat up many villains
with that superpower but I would be able
to deploy my superior knowledge to
create computer learning algorithms that
predict where the villains will strike
next
then cowardly warn the police here that
concept definitely needs some polishing
before it's made into a superhero flick
and you asked when I was a child what
did I want to be when I was really young
I wanted to be a scientist but as I grew
up I saw myself going into either
engineering or computer science both
fields always interested me and still do
but as is usually the case I ended up
doing neither I really can't thank you
enough for helping me to reach such an
amazing milestone reaching 1 million
subscribers is by far the most
astonishing thing I've ever accomplished
you maintain your life I just really
can't believe it's happened to me so
thank you and here's to many more years
of 42
you